you're perfect hey Sabrina carpenter we
have been huge fans of yours for years
we loved watching you on the Disney
Channel and we can't get enough of your
music I don't know if you guys know this
song but if you don't I'm gonna teach it
to you so we were delighted to find out
that you scored a role in that original
Netflix movie tall girl
Netflix made a great decision to cast
you as the older sister of the main
character this movie looks so great and
we just know that you're going to give
it everything you've got let's get to
work
Sabrina carpenter is one of the hottest
stars right now she is starring in the
Netflix original movie tall girl keep
watching to find out everything you need
to know about Sabrina carpenter dig
little sister in tall girl Sabrina plays
Harper who is the older sister of Jody
Jody is 16 years old and over six feet
tall Harper calls Jody a big little
sister because she's younger but taller
that makes Harper the big little sister
Jody comes to Harper for a makeover she
wants more confidence and Harper is the
perfect one to give it to her
after all what are big sisters for these
two have such a great chemistry that we
totally believe that they are siblings
definitely not Saul Ava Michelle who
plays Jody is over six feet tall and
even though Sabrina plays her sister
you'll notice that there is a major
height difference when you see these two
together Sabrina looks super short
Sabrina is over a foot shorter than Ava
she is barely five feet tall in real
life we know that siblings don't all
have to be the same height but this is
such a big difference sixteen years old
six foot one we wonder how the movie
will explain these two sisters Heights
beauty-queen there's a lot more to
Sabrina's character in tall girl than
just being a sister while Jody isn't
super glamorous
oh boy grandma's couch Harper is she's
literally a beauty queen we see her
onstage at the Miss Louisiana pageant
she uses her beauty queen skills to help
Jody she says I'm going to extreme
makeover the crap out of you that is
just too funny but she helps Jody find
her inner confidence and that's what
being a beauty queen is all about real
life sisters Sabrina may be great at
playing a big sister but in real life
she is the baby of the family she has
two older sisters one is named Shannon
and the other is Sarah yes they all have
names that start with us how cute is
that
a carpenter has done a little bit of
acting yeah that's right
and she has a huge social media
following on Instagram and Tumblr we bet
Sabrina learned how to play a great
older sister from her real-life sisters
the next Miley when Sabrina was just 10
years old she was already trying to get
her acting and singing career off the
ground she was in a reality singing
competition called to the next Miley
Cyrus project more you would submit a
video of you singing it was hosted by
none other than Miley Cyrus Sabrina was
so adorable that she was in the
competition she placed third within a
couple of years her career really took
off you looked me up a little
Sabrina's still considers Miley to be an
inspiration what else does she have in
common with Miley keep watching to find
out Disney Channel days Sabrina got most
of her fame from her days on the Disney
Channel she guest-starred in Phineas and
Ferb and Austin and Ally's before she
got a big role then she was cast in Girl
Meets World as Maya Hart she also
appeared in adventures in babysitting
Disney helped her get her singing career
started too she even sang the theme song
for Sophia the first she voiced princess
Vivian in that series to all of us
together as a team she is definitely
another Disney Channel success story
songwriter vibes
Sabrina isn't just a talented actress
and singer she's also a songwriter when
she was on the Disney Channel her songs
were written for her but she used to
write songs in her free time on set of
Girl Meets World
once the show ended she was ready for
the next step she pursued music outside
of the Disney Channel with her own songs
and she has been hugely successful with
it you guys sold out every show I'm not
gonna tell you how much I love you
because I already know she has such a
soulful voice don't read the comments
Bena celebrity definitely has its
downsides Sabrina is only 20 and she has
over 18 million followers on Instagram
she is pretty modest about this though
and says half of them are probably fake
accounts people can be super mean on the
internet especially to celebrities
we're very dramatic on his strengths
being in the public eye causes her a lot
of anxiety so sabrina has a rule for
herself she never reached the common
honestly we think that is a great idea
Netflix queen we are so glad that
Sabrina is continuing her acting career
after her contract with the Disney
Channel ended
life moves fast life does a good job her
main focus was music but she is back in
it in Hollywood and she was picked up by
Netflix not only is she starring and
tall girl but she is also working on
another Netflix original movie it's
called work it she plays a girl who has
to win a dance competition to get into
the College of her dreams this movie is
currently filming and we can't wait to
watch it new album sabrina has recently
released her fourth studio album it came
out in July
2019 the album is called singular act 2
it's essentially a sequel to her
previous album singular act 1 it's been
getting amazing reviews
she is genuine and full of soul in the
new album Sabrina is all about being
authentic to herself and the story is
not telling her my life and yeah pushing
20 and exhale are two of the hottest
singles from the album what's your
favorite Sabrina carpenter song tell us
in the comments thanks for watching for
more great videos about your favorite
stars be sure to subscribe to the things
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up we'll catch you next time
[Music]